- Let's listen to some music,
you got a playlist--
- Oh yeah.
- That you like?
- All my music is good, man.
Just put it on random.
- Alright.
Rock it out.
- This is an audio
journal of my experiments
on my own human condition.
(laughs) Forgot
this was on here.
Let's skip ahead.
- Oh no, no, no.
No, no, I wanna...
I wanna hear your
thoughts on things.
- Tasted my own urine today to
make sure I was still human.
Yeah, let's just skip ahead.
- What the fuck is this?
- It's just some voice memos.
My experiments are going well.
I'm hours into my
daylong commitment
to stare at myself
in the mirror nude.
I'm beginning to see
my reptilian self.
I am the lizard.
I taste the bug on my tongue.
- Don't touch it.
- I just--
- I have committed myself to
understanding what a woman
feels like when
she is penetrated.
I want to fulfill
this commitment
but the matchstick
won't fit in my penis.
Too square.
- Too square?
How 'bout...
Forget it.
- My penis.
- I understand.
- Is too square.
- I understand...
What?
(Jordan screaming)
- Why? Why? Why?
(intense screaming)
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Stupid, stupid, stupid!
I'm so fundamentally lonely.
I'm adrift in an
indifferent universe.
Only Keegan tethers
me to reality.
I'll take a drive
with him tomorrow.
I wonder if he senses how I
feed off of his lifeforce.
Different Keegan.
(beatbox music)